hello and welcome to world stories your
international reporters magazine im sue
misawa's ganda on this week's edition
we'll find out why bamboo could be the
key to Colombia's future we ride with
the Cossacks and how an ancient
Vietnamese performance art is getting a
new lease on life all that and more
coming up but first it's been more than
a decade since the fighting in Darfur
began but the situation in western Sudan
is still unstable ethnic conflict is
continuing their and millions have been
displaced by the violence and the midst
of those troubles we find a program
that's trying to help rebuild the
communities that have been torn apart a
unique Detention Center is giving young
men who've gotten into trouble with the
law a chance to learn a trade valuable
skills that can help them provide some
economic stability for their families un
TVs Nathan barreiro brings us this story
here in Sudan's Darfur region one young
man's life is on the verge of a radical
transformation
eighteen-year-old ezaki abdullah gafas
will soon be released from this juvenile
prison in North Darfur where he has
spent the past four years on
manslaughter charges though he has
forgotten how to write Al's aki has
enlisted some help to draft this letter
to his mother my kind mother Laura I
missed you and have not seen you for a
long time I am now completing my jail
sentence and will come to see you
greetings to my brothers and sisters
your son al Zackie Zackie was jailed at
the age of 14 for killing a classmate in
a fight they had quarreled outside
school and ezaki attacked him with a
stick accidentally inflicting fatal
wounds I regret it very much I didn't
mean to cause problems I was a troubled
youth now I've lost many years of my
life but since I transferred to this
Center I've learned many things after
two years of incarceration al Zaki was
transferred to this juvenile detention
center the only one of its kind in all
of Darfur it receives young offenders
from across the region once a week the
inmates travel to a training center
where they are given a unique
opportunity
they are taught vocational skills that
will help them reintegrate into society
and become useful members of their
communities he's coming into the prison
is like giving him a second chance in
that we will be able to have a
livelihood yeah and also a way to
support himself and also to support his
family members John ammonia is a
corrections advisor with UNAMID the
African Union and United Nations hybrid
operation in Darfur most of these bodies
are void soon grabbing arrested by the
police after the displacement of their
families who currently are in some of
the ID becomes ten years of war in
Darfur has forced over two million
people to flee their homes many now live
in camps for internally displaced people
where they lack access to basic health
care and education economic hardship and
high unemployment rates have brought a
surge in violence across the region but
the new initiative is helping give young
offenders from these communities another
chance the United Nations is working
with the government of Sudan to improve
prison facilities and provide prisoners
with rehabilitation programs inmates can
choose between a variety of vocational
skills including masonry welding and
auto mechanics
the program also trains prison staff so
that they may teach the skills to
inmates so far 16 prison staff and 22
juvenile inmates have taken part Khaleel
Muhammad Badawi is the director of the
technical school that provides the
training abundant foie gras has a lokita
allah tala when these boys are
unemployed they are more likely to
commit crimes but if they learn a trade
and get a job he will stay away from a
life of crime and economic eager to
learn a new skill al Zaki Abdullah
ghaffar chose to train as a bricklayer
building on these skills that is a fire
when he's in prison we believe that this
boy and still be a very useful member of
the society at last al sakis big day has
arrived he has served his sentence and
is being sent home to his family with
his newfound freedom comes new
responsibilities
his family has long awaited his return
especially his mother
I'm to thank God for his safe return
it's an emotional reunion how cozy is
looking forward to enjoying a fresh
start and he wants to use his newly
gained skills to provide for his family
in Columbia cash crops are a big part of
the country's growing export industry
from coffee to sugarcane vast amounts of
forest land have been raised to make way
for farm plantations now that's
endangered valuable species and created
all sorts of environmental issues too
but there could be an answer to those
problems the trustee bamboo plant it's a
fast growing grass that's been
cultivated and used for building in
Colombia for many years now two
organizations are taking a new approach
to bamboo proving that it could be the
key to a sustainable future and social
development reporter Yuri bruschetta
explains every four years Diego Lopez
and yogg stem from the eco bamboo
company come to the forest to harvest
guadua a South American species of
bamboo guadua can grow to a height of
thirty meters within four years though
bamboos are grasses guadua is as hard as
wood okay they will see you we make sure
that water doesn't gather in the stump
after we cut down the bamboo otherwise
the moisture on the surface attracts
insects and the stump starts to rot and
that would be bad for the rest of the
plants guadua springs up in forest
clearings near streams and rivers in the
Amazon basin it can grow 20 centimeters
a day kwadwo also fixes large amounts of
carbon dioxide stems are usually cut
when they're four years old then they're
processed for use in the construction
industry
vamos isn't fantastisch is Palmer bamboo
is a fantastic material for use in
building the long slender stems really
fire up the imagination you can do so
much with them we're standing in a
natural Cathedral these long stems are
also lightweight the possibilities are
endless you can do so much you just have
to break free of standard ways of
thinking straight lines rectangles think
outside the box just let yourself be
inspired by this Gothic cathedral for
example with its gentle curves it's
wonderful help us the 200 children who
go to school in the town of Montebello
in western Colombia have long since
learned to appreciate Wadhwa that's
because their school is made of it
Colombians used to build houses out of
guadua centuries ago poor people's
houses which tended to fall apart after
a few years but with modern techniques
bamboo buildings are pretty robust the
school for a life project was founded by
the German Colombian architect Andres
Bella who also designed the complex the
aim of the project is to help people
help themselves to provide a basic
education so they can live their lives
and earn money in an upright and decent
way funding came from Germany and the
Colombian government Bianca Clayton I
came here to create a different kind of
architecture I said we have to do modern
architecture using this traditional
natural material bamboo guadua just
springs up all over it's like a weed
most of the children are from very poor
families some started using drugs at an
early age their time at the school with
its open architecture should help them
grow strong and independent
Beppe lewood also like to improve
domestic architecture in Columbia the
blue spotted in the homes they build
here are just little boxes rabbit
hutches for people dinner the man for
security people lock themselves
indicated compounds surrounded by a
fence with a guard at the entrance and
guard dogs just to be safe and inside
these compounds you have all these limit
boxes that pass for houses small houses
and roads so everybody has his own house
but inside these homes you can hardly
move the natural materials that were
commonly used in early times are
disappearing what I want to do is bring
these materials back into use and there
is a Colombian way of doing architecture
and one key element is bamboo mr.
bumbles in the workshop next to the
school youngsters are learning to work
with guadua
I'm please Olivia enough in my village
there are no bamboo houses at least not
yet I really enjoy my training here one
day I'll be able to build houses myself
with guadua I think it oh I I would look
at us and teach other boys in my village
see before guadua can be used it has to
be cured the eco bamboo company has a
factory about two hours drive from on to
beoh the stems are first freed of
bacteria and insects
then they're bathed in a solution of
boric salts which are not considered a
health hazard beppe LA and Young's Tom
who owns eco bamboo are both concerned
about protecting the environment they
want people to use more guadua and less
wood many species of hardwood are
endangered kwadwo can replace wood in
many contexts the government however is
not investing heavily in bamboo but in
cane sugar which is a major export item
millions of hectares of forests are
being cut down to make way for
plantations guadua could be a compromise
between economic and ecological concerns
des mots moshpit massive one option
would be to plant lots and lots of
bamboo along roads and riverbanks we
don't have to turn large areas of
farmland back into forests we can plant
bamboo forests just on waste ground or
less valuable land deed unbeatable it
can be used in the construction industry
and thus benefit farmers and day
laborers that would take the pressure
off the rain forest because if we carry
on the way we're going at the moment 20
or 30 years there won't be any virgin
forest left in Colombia sponsors
possession kind without mazon more than
50,000 hectares of bamboo are under
cultivation in Colombia more than a
million people in the country are in
urgent need of a decent home boosting
the guadua industry could help solve the
housing problem and protect the
rainforest a promising plant indeed now
to an ancient sporting event in Russia
that's been brought back to life [ __ ]
Tosca as it's known as a complex mix of
acrobatics on horseback and martial arts
it's a tradition that dates back
hundreds of years but it wasn't
practiced in the Soviet Union these days
though the sport is gaining popularity
once again artis waffa da we went along
to an event near Moscow to watch the
best riders in Russia square off against
each other and put their skills to the
test
young Oleg is a cossack from Volgograd
at just 9 years old he already rides
like a professional today he's showing
his horse particular affection to
strengthen the bond between them in
preparation for their participation in
the Russian jiggy toka competition rod
school I like riding backwards
especially when I'm sitting on the
horse's neck and I can jump back from
there into the saddle it is Corky the
horsemanship on display during the jig
atoka is certainly impressive
contestants execute intricate moves on
horseback showing off their acrobatic
abilities the sport requires great skill
who evolves intense training you talk
good the Cossacks are proud of the tough
guy it's an ancient art form the dates
back centuries apart which was not
practiced during the Soviet era my
father reintroduced it through the
circus it took seven years of
researching training to bring the
tradition back to life now the
organizers are hosting competitions and
tournaments that are open to all young
and old and men and women
sucka katana modern it's like a brand
new sport we wrote the rules ourselves
and we'll modify them from one year to
the next at the moment we have four
categories which are organized according
to age gender tricks and level Bryan
Bulaga 110 riders of various Russian
ethnicities have come from across the
country to take part in the competition
every participant is rewarded for their
hard work by giving prizes to everyone
the organizers help to motivate them to
continue nurturing the Russian tradition
granny Osaka Kyoto be statue I would
like to see this sport spread across
Russia in the next five years with Boise
orbit we need more organization in terms
of prizes referees and martial arts
Boyka kita in addition to writing talent
competitors must demonstrate expert
fighting skills using guns and swords
the wood jig atoka means courage and
bravery characteristics that the riders
have shown today they've all risen to
the occasion and brought the sport back
to life Gingka has gone through several
different phases over the years it's
been a martial art you used to defend
Russian territory and the circus act is
at least now I did away let's enforce it
nowadays it's fans hope it will serve as
a link between past and present and will
be recognized as a sport both in Russia
and other parts of the world yeah when I
lemn raha da we r t near Moscow thanks
to RT for that report we move on to
Lebanon now where we meet a designer who
uses fashion to pay tribute to his
country's past designer Raja habashi is
something of a nostalgic he finds
pictures showing what the capital Beirut
once looked like and transforms them
into modern handbags his aim is to
celebrate Lebanon's culture and he hopes
he can inspire others young and old to
do the same Nadine mallu from mbc takes
a closer look
a longing for old Lebanon and its
historic hallmarks motivated Raja
habashi to make special use of old
photographs he decided to combine his
professional experience of designing and
producing bags with his love of faded
snapshots of his native country
imprinting forgotten images onto women's
handbags he has found an innovative way
to promote a cultural historical
understanding of the country's heritage
other places hehe in john's ocular i
want to remind people about the historic
face of old lebanon by the by a place
where people once lived in peace
together before lying and rudeness
became customary is there but and i let
me down these days many Lebanese
citizens want to leave and many already
have what I want to say to them is come
back let's rocket this together and not
run away from every difficulty it's
worth doing it for our country which is
still very beautiful you know I mean
Darwin margam we're also working with
save beirut heritage which has already
prevented the demolition of between 130
and 140 buildings in building Albert
among them are traditional old style
apartments complete with courtyards
sayin my roots heritage stood in front
of them and stop them from being knocked
down my jaan we gave them a percentage
of every sale so they can continue their
work longer raja wants to motivate
members of the younger generation to
form a deep bond with Lebanon he wants
to stop them from automatically thinking
they have to leave whenever their
country is struck by economic or
political difficulties
the National concept military bond it
all started with the nineteen thirty
photograph of Jamaica streets I chose
the shot to launch the project because
the location is close to my old school
velesh Sofia teenagers had a second one
I used them is this one of the rock
which was taken in 1908 food Cameron hot
then the third is also from 1930 and
shows nesma square so we began with
photos that are around a hundred years
old the holiest when they can also come
in a pyridine Reshiram boom it's an A
and AB Atkinson kill it ARM arm and kill
Alyssa customers range in age and have
very different styles this way my son I
should be living in a pocket in a
phenomenal many of them lived here in
the 50s and 60s and they're happy with
our products because they say they take
them on a trip down memory lane listen
or Fiona and I'm clear with a chef it
muscle and Lyra yeah and I'm feeling
have a lot of interest from Lebanese
people living abroad li xin back and
also from young people who yearn for the
past well many le hago Haneen pattle
island young generation y ella de merna
and be around we buy some of our images
online but others we create ourselves by
making Holograms or motifs or by
photoshopping them to create a vintage
feel effector my jaan because vintage
become establish when I leave
Raja's creativity is inspired by the
beauty of his country
but he also uses images from old local
or foreign adverts for cars in addition
to his bags Raja makes jewelry and
designs fabrics
and finally today we bring you a story
about Tuan it's an ancient Vietnamese
performance art that dates back a
thousand years to one reached its high
point in the seventeenth and eighteenth
centuries when it was performed at the
royal court it slipped in popularity
ever since and has gone out of fashion
these days but a few theaters in Hanoi
are working to bring the art form back
to life their strategy if the locals in
the capital aren't interested drawn a
foreign audience V TVs window kman tells
us more some long water puppet theater
puts on three performances every night
of the week
taking in a water puppetry show has
become an indispensable part of any tour
of Hanoi
but the theater had to overcome initial
challenges to achieve its current
success we conduct surveys annually to
gather opinions from tourism companies
about tourists interests and one time
slots our best and most convenient for
our shows at the beginning we only did
three shows a week you look mad we're
going but now we have a lot more
customers 11 days in the coma boy who
imagines an missoula technically fangs
and lame things look different at the
viet nam trung theater when the curtain
goes up here on a typical night many
seats are empty the theater is also
located in Hanoi sold quarter but it
puts on just two shows a week at some
performances there are fewer people in
the audience and there are one stage
but the theaters management is working
to change that Kubiak market hub we got
the computer cooperating with tourism
companies is very important for our
theater pina la it supports our goal of
promoting the unique tuan culture to
foreign tourists also cooperating like
this will help us market ourselves as a
tourist product a must-see for tourists
visiting Hanoi Yap alone then we handle
the theaters new plan has received
positive feedback from tourism companies
and their clients seem to enjoy what
they see on stage I have seen Indonesian
theater in Bali it's somewhat similar a
lot of animals involved in dance and
music so really enjoyed the the
performance it was very informative and
I learned a lot about Vietnam and how
past cultures lived and about the music
and the life so yeah it was very
interesting yes I do domu our company is
experimenting with including 12 shows
and our tours and so far it's been
promising tourists are surprised by the
long history of Tuan and Vietnam most of
our clients really enjoy the shows by
promoting too long to foreign tourists
Vietnam duong theater is giving the
traditional art form a chance to grow
and develop if it's to survive in the
modern world too long must escape the
confines of the theater and become
recognized as part of viet nam's
cultural heritage
well that's all for this edition of
world stories will leave you with this
week's picks of the world see you next
time
you